I think he is truly the only person in
the five plus year history of the show
when we had human beings who are coming
in here we can't wait for the next time
to do this show and then go right to a
waiting planet at the Los Angeles
International Airport that's away I
forget what he was promoting at the time
maybe last night on earth right right
which was a great show on Fox now he is
the voice of shaggy you bet he is in
Scoob exclamation point that my kids
insisted that we watch on Friday night
and I watched every glorious frame of
this I guess that makes my children
those meddling kids
he is Will Forte how are you will I'm
doing great how are you I'm great it was
I just I love chatting with you I'll
just say that right off the bat with you
funny you you make my my plane trip
seems so much cooler than than it wasn't
well let me let me add about the last
plane trip that I took with you will if
you don't mind me saying it was on the
way back from the big slick when you
were passed out the whole way because I
think you did karaoke up until the time
we we took off well oh yeah you know I'm
gonna expend all my my body's energy
resources on anything it's gonna be
character I was gonna say that to my
kids you know hey for daddy points you
know the voice is shaggy I watched him
passed out an entire flight home from
Los Angeles of gotta tell you I mean you
you understand you understand the voice
of shaggy and the significance of this
role in pop culture history and how did
you take this one on will this is big
this is Bay Time stuff sir it was
terrifying I mean it was it what an
honor to be asked to do it but but
there's some big shoes to fill I mean
Casey Kasem sir an icon and and Matthew
Lillard was awesome too so so it was it
was scary but but it was it was fun to
do did you like how do you like you
download previous episodes or like how
do how does one prepare for shaggy a
bunch of stuff but my my studying
something I remember I did Beerfest and
I had to be a German guy and
you're fast and I study the audio like a
CD on German like the first-year German
studies and then also a specific thing
that was how to speak with the German
accent and I felt like a month I did
this and I still went and did beer fest
and sounded way more Chinese than German
yes so so you're saying you'd do a
better shaggy than you do a German beer
fest guy that's a thing as much
preparation as I can do it still sounds
like what my kids loved it man we did
the whole family did it was great we
spent the whole front and I want you to
buy movie at the front there's so much
good there's all these awesome Anna
Barbera characters that I grew up loving
it was really fun to be a part of I know
it's just like you know I don't know how
to if I was dating myself to tell my
kids I know all about Captain Caveman
you know I know all about dynomutt you
know they were very excited that Ken
Jong because they're big masked singer
people you know hearing Tracy Morgan as
Captain Caveman was a phenomenal twist
on the character you know the funniest
guy I mean all those guys so many funny
people in this movie growing Tracy
Morgan I mean she's that guy is so funny
everything it was great it really really
was terrific so congrats Congrats on
that you got it so you're still imagine
a die-hard Raider fan is that Jo would I
be assumed assuming you know my my
status is in question right now you know
they're there obviously everyone knows
they're moving to Las Vegas I as a
person born in Oakland yes that's tough
for me to take that I feel like the fans
in Oakland were very loyal and it is
upsetting that they're leaving them so
um you are you are just on its it you're
not gonna follow them to to Vegas we I
don't know I don't know I I know I'm not
going to did you just make that decision
live on the Rich Eisen show yeah leaning
towards it it's been very upsetting but
I don't know
I'm dead you know you don't just switch
allegiances to another team right it's
more just that I would become anti
Raiders okay just root for anybody who
was against them but I don't think I
have that in me either it's like they've
given me so much pleasure in my life it
just will never be exactly the same so I
don't think that all I'm just trying to
figure out what what it's what it is in
my head and I don't know that all I
don't know that I'll know until I see
them playing in Vegas right I don't know
how it's all gonna shake out so you're
as of now I'm upset with them because I
just feel like they've you know they're
all these people so many great Raiders
teams over the years but then let's be
honest there was a stretch where they
were not great and I felt like the
Raiders fans hung in there with them and
and packed that place and we're great
fans and and then all of a sudden you
know they they move the team so you
upset the Warriors moved to the San
Francisco huh I want everybody in
Oakland yeah why not I mean you got as
long as you're asking that sort of thing
you should be able to do that I'm
wondering if I could put you on the spot
for some comedy Will Forte
we all need a laugh we only laugh and
you can provide these things but I'm
gonna put you on the spot for some
comedy you've been to the black hole I
assume correct yeah okay
you have a voiced shaggy in Scoob
exclamation point which by the way is
that is that a silent exclamation point
er I need to say Scoob when I when I say
it I think you have to enunciate the
okay Scooby you have played you have
played shaggy and Scoob okay can you
describe a black hole experience that's
using the voice of shaggy can you give
me your favorite black hole memory in
the voice of shaggy Will Forte would you
mind doing that for me can you do
I don't know it's not like it's not like
riding a bike you've got you've got a
really before even when I was doing it I
was studying it it still was hit miss I
will say that I got a chance to go into
wasn't I was I've definitely been in the
black hole several times I somehow made
friends with the villapiano's family
Phil villapiano's his daughter Andrea
and and their sons and it and so yes
getting to walk around Oakland Coliseum
with royalty like that we had so much
fun and I got to hang out with with Phil
and Anne Frank O'Hara's who are good
buds who can hand I think they injected
Franco Harris into the Hall of Fame into
the into the black hole Hall of Fame oh
I wouldn't I didn't even know that sort
of thing Will Forte what actually exists
so I got to watch that happen and I
think I might have even gotten to
introduce I got to be like part of the
undercard of that announcement like like
oh and here's you know now nobody nobody
cares but here's Will Forte to say a few
words I could and then and then you know
led over to them you know we did to Phil
right saying something about Franco and
they went nuts as they should you know
he was such a sweet guy and people
really know so they should be very
respect so did we just determine that
it's easier to do a German accent on the
spot than the shaggy accent on the spot
for you he's very much easier actually
to me sounded pretty German now would
you have the use of une like unnerved
and and a th which turns to a Z now
would have been better if Tom Brady had
sawn with the Raiders would you have
followed them to Las Vegas if Brady had
actually signed with the Raiders
Will Forte no not even there have
nothing to do with it
Wow okay you're I mean I like all the
storylines don't get me wrong I love let
you know I'm so excited to see what
happens at Tampa Tampa Bay for him and
it's you know but but and and it's you
know I'm I'm a fan of football right but
I'm a I'm a die-hard Oakland Raiders and
Raiders there you go
you know but we'll see we'll see - you
know - it changes happen you got to
adapt to change so I just I just you
know it's been thinking about it in a
hypothetical sense
I haven't had to see the actual reality
of it yet
so okay so it's not easy to do a shaggy
on the spot how about Casey Kasem
long-distance dedication to an Oakland
Raider fan from Las Vegas I'll see what
I can do he'll be boys but I just
couldn't I could I was closer on on the
actual bottom rung the low yes and then
when I would try to raise it up it just
wasn't the name the vagaries of the
voice work a man I've done voiceover
work with you for 22 Jump Street
yeah I've done it I still get my five
cent residual checks are yours more than
five cents tell me did they pay you more
than they paid me it's okay if they do
no no no hey it was great to chat with
you will it's been way too long
my kids and I we loved school Scoob we
loved it available now on digital
released on Friday and people can go get
it and it was amazing so congrats I
can't wait to see in person yeah back in
one of those big flicks know me to let
everyone at Children's Mercy Hospital in
Kansas City and everybody in the country
in the world you're the man will thanks
to the chat good talk in the app you go
that's will fortune hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here